just blinding like an operator like I'm
not when you can do something with the
operator thing like a surgeon I like
that
[Music]
where where it gets really interesting
is culture culture is the hidden
retention of it all it's been really
fascinating for me to watch people it
makes sense pick happiness over finance
even in their 20s or maybe especially in
their 20s it's a super interesting
literally the conversation was having
outside yeah we are we've gone to a
heavy kind of a very entry-level model
we we are building almost like a
dumbbell going very heavy up top going
incredibly systematic at the bottom and
being very scrutinizing our middle where
there's enormous hidden garbage be at
the mercy of the individual instead of
creating vince mcmahon did it right
right he's gonna bring you in he's gonna
name you he now owns that name like you
know you're not Brutus the barber
beefcake you're not
Hillbilly Jim you know and then you know
and babble tell you up that's kind of
what I've done for my team like I've
built such a brand that like a talk show
like I like them they're good there's
continuity but it's hard for me to like
it's a little hard because I'm a human
it's a small team but as a business
model it's what I want to replicate
because I don't know there's a thousand
people lined up willing to work for free
we change in the lace I think there
might be regular laces in them yeah but
this is the you know yeah
it's getting really fun how are you
great man what's been going on yeah
how's it ending no I feel like I'm
talking to you
I'm trying to think about but that's why
I'm thinking about every variable
something okay there's that you know to
your point there's something I've you
you know you've gotten to know me a
little bit the thing that I'm worried
about is I sabotage relationships
because I give so much I do the wrong
thing I do the right thing so much that
I get upset and then I do the wrong
thing scarcity versus volume all of this
is a supply and demand game right so
let's talk about this
when does the 0:03 come out okay make
some note well somebody yeah me make
some notes what a blog dealing with a
little bit of a fire right now with a
client and a call in two minutes just
had like a swiss 20:18 meeting
about some possible business
partnerships heading to the LA office
now bunch of meetings there then heading
to airport heading to London for the
holiday party
and some business meetings there so just
a little la London combo here to wrap up
the year and here with my main man
babban
and when you say connecting I'll [ __ ]
fly-in and fly-out to have a breakfast
lunch and dinner because again I need
you guys to know this this is more about
how I feel about myself as a man then
about the size of the financial
vulnerability the pleasure
I love the Eagles gear sorry about
Carson hey guys
happy holidays hey guys hi hi hi ru was
good it was last night
pretty good what up Instagram I wanna
jump on and say hey hey hey my voice is
a little suspect keep losing it
knowing this cold good to see you what
up people throwing up to five I like
that rothenburg good to see Trinidad
James the man Thank You Trinidad James
headed to London right now in the LA
office
real good got a lot done just binding
like an operator we do something with
the operators going like a surgeon I
like that
good to see you Happy Holidays to
everybody I see a lot of you getting
your thing I just posted this video for
a lot of you that you need to see let me
give you a really good piece of advice
and make sure your parents watch this
video you can always get a job like like
you can do whatever they want and what
you want very easily you can go and play
lacrosse in college you can you can try
out for major league lacrosse teams
you can either succeed or fail but I got
good news for you when you're 27 which
is a ridiculous young man you can just
go get a job that's true you can go get
a job but you can never go back bro you
can never go back to 21 years old and
kind of you know take that leap of faith
so like just just you know plan you're
so young but like plan but just do it
bro
[ __ ] that
it lands in Japan who stood in line for
Washington but nice departure until
it should be aiming at a c41 with you
[Music]
[Music]